Salut, aujourd'hui c'est un nouvel épisode
du "Boost Brain",
avec Laetitia de la chaîne :
Le Corps, la Maison, l'Esprit.
Il y a un an, jour pour jour,
j'ai rencontré Laetitia ici,
à Aix-en-Provence,
dans cet appartement.
Et on le refait ici, un an plus tard
c'est un petit peu notre pèlerinage.
Le but du jeu :
de voir, si avec ma technique,
Laetitia arrivera à retenir un jeu
de cartes dans sa tête.
C'est parti :
"Boost Brain".
[Musique Générique]
Laetitia : Alors Fabien Olicard
va essayer de me rendre intelligente.
Ce n'est pas gagné d'avance.
Tout à l'heure il a essayé de m'apprendre
la droite et la gauche.
[Rires]
Fabien : Ce n'etait pas si évident...
parce qu'elle m'a dit :
"ça dépend de qui tu es."
L : Mais bien sûr ! Tout le monde n'a pas la même droite et la même gauche !
F : Boost Brain !
Pour ceux qui ont suivi
cette nouvelle série, que j'avais
commencé à entamer très légèrement
fin 2016, mais plus 2017
avec Amixem,
a pour but d'apprendre quelque chose
à vous, de vous donner une astuce,
mais surtout, que quelqu'un le fasse en même temps.
Comme ça, ça vous prouve
que ça fonctionne
et que vous pouvez le faire
vous aussi.
Ce qui est plutôt cool.
Le but du jeu, c'est de retenir
un jeu de cartes en entier.
D'accord ?
[Soupir d'inquiétude de Laetitia]
F : Je ne vais pas le faire en entier
parce que ça va être trop long.
Il y a deux techniques à connaître
et je t'ai demandé si tu connaissais
les palais mentaux,
et tu m'as dit que non.
L : Non.
F : Donc, du coup, on ne va faire
qu'une partie.
On va faire un maximum
de ce qu'on peut.
On va déjà se créer un palais mental
rapidement,
je te dirai après, tout à l'heure,
à quoi çà sert.
F : J'aimerais que tu imagines,
L [affirmative] : Humm, Humm
F: un endroit que tu connais
particulièrement bien.
L : Ah ! Ma cuisine !
F : Ta cuisine.
Euh... si tu pars vers la gauche
on va faire le tour de ta cuisine,
de la gauche vers la droite...
L : Attends ! Oui mais il faut que je me mette
dans le sens de ma cuisine !
F : Ta gauche à toi !
L : Attends...mais...que...par rapport...
l'entrée elle est vers là !
Là, ici, il y a tous les trucs avec
les tasses, les assiettes, les machins...
F : Ok. Les tasses, les assiettes,
d'accord.
L : Sur ma gauche.
F : Ok. Ça marche.
L : Après, en face de moi il y a
mon évier, la machine à laver et
et le truc pour faire à manger.
F : Dans cet ordre là ?
L : Oui.
F : Évier, machine à laver...
F: et quoi ?
L : Et la plaque pour faire à manger.
F : La plaque de cuisson, d'accord.
L : Ensuite, il y a toute la partie
qui donne sur mon salon,
tu sais ? J'ai une grande vitre...
qui donne sur mon salon.
F : C'est une vitre ? Ce n'est pas un passe,
c'est une vitre quoi...
L : C'est une vitre.
F : D'accord. Ok.
L : Et ensuite, j'ai le mur...
de là où on...
de ce dont je te parlais tout à l'heure.
F [Approbateur] : Humm, humm.
L : Où il y a tous mes trucs de manger
plus le meuble avec le four.
L : Voilà. Sauf que dans le truc de...
tu sais, de l'évier, machin...
bon, ce n'est pas dans ce sens là,
c'est genre : machine à laver, évier.
F : Ah, d'accord ! Donc d'abord
machine à laver et après évier ?
L : Oui.
F : D'accord.
F : Là, tu ne le sais pas encore,
mais on vient de te créer un palais mental
très rapidement.
L : D'accord.
F : Un petit.
[Laetita s'éclaircit la gorge]
F : qui a plusieurs spots,
on va les compter ensemble :
on a les tasses. On a, donc,
d'abord la machine à laver,
ensuite l'évier, les plaques de cuissons,
la vitre et la machine pour le four.
Vous qui suivez la chaîne,
vous savez ce qu'est un palais mental.
Si vous ne savez pas, vous regardez
dans la playlist "Mémoire"
c'est expliqué.
Et c'est très utile.
Là c'est un palais mental avec 6 spots.
On va pouvoir déposer des choses,
mentalement, là-dedans.
Maintenant, pour apprendre
le jeu de cartes,
on va apprendre l'ordre
des séquences rouges-noires.
C'est quelque chose que j'avais expliqué,
il y a longtemps, sur la chaîne,
et, en parlant avec des abonnés,
peu de personnes osent essayer de le faire
parce qu'elles pensent que c'est trop compliqué,
L : C'est ce que je pense, maintenant
que tu dis çà.
F : Voilà. Et que ça ne marche pas.
Donc, on va le faire ensemble.
On va apprendre les séquences
juste rouges et noires, tu vois ?
Après tu seras capable de dire :
rouge, noire, rouge, noire, noire...
F : rouge, noire, rouge, noire, noire, noire, rouge
L : D'accord.
F : Ce qui est déjà pas mal du tout.
F : Ça c'est 1. Noir c'est 1.
L : Noir c'est 1.
F : Rouge, c'est un peu plus vide,
c'est plus léger,
F : donc c'est zéro.
L : Ah!
F : Tu me dis...
L : Je dois te dire quoi ? Zéro ou 1 ?
F : 1 ou zéro.
[Accéléré - On entend Laetitia dire 1 ou 0
et Fabien répondre par oui, oui, oui...]
[Vitesse normale]
L : 1, 0, 0
F : Oui, oui, oui.
F : Ok.
L : Ok !
F : Donc tu es capable de le faire.
[Rires de Laetitia]
F : Maintenant, je t'ai dit qu'on allait
les apprendre 3 par 3.
F : Et pour ça, il y a plein de
possibilités différentes.
ça c'est toutes les possibilités
de séquences qui existent.
Et bien ça, on va le convertir,
dans notre tête, avec des chiffres.
Le 1, il est à droite.
Tu es d'accord avec moi ?
L : Oui.
F : Sur ces 3 cartes là,
on a : 0, 0, 1.
Et le 1, il est... à droite.
F : La droite, elle est toujours de ce côté là,
[Laetitia éclate de rire]
F : par rapport à toi.
Et  la gauche, ici.
F : Il n'y a pas de : "par rapport à qui..."
L : Il n'y a pas d'arnaque.
F : Il n'y a pas "par rapport à qui, à quoi",
c'est que par rapport à toi.
La droite, elle est là.
F : Ok ?
L : D'accord.
F : Donc là, le 1 il est est à droite.
Comme il est à droite,
ça commence par un D
on va penser à Donald.
L : Il est au milieu !
F : Et bien avec le M,
on va penser à Milou !
F : Ça marche ?
L : Ouais.
F : A gauche, ça fait G,
de Gargamel...
L : Gargamel... Ok.
F : Ça roule ?
F : Là, on voit que les deux 1
sont de chaque côté,
ils encerclent, en fait, le rouge.
Avec le E de "encercler",
on va faire quelque chose :
on va faire Excalibur.
L : A ce stade là,
F : Ouais ?
L : est-ce que tu as toujours
foi en moi ?
F : Ouais.
L : Ok.
F : Là, il y a trois 1.
On peut dire que c'est
la version Ultime des 1.
1,1,1
1 c'est ultime,
ultime c'est Hulk.
Là, il y en a zéro d'héros.
L [Approuvant] : Humm, humm
F : Zéro, comme... Zorro.
Là on a deux 1 qui sont à droite
Deux à droite...
Donc ça fait D, D.
Comme Dédé de la Française des jeux,
tu te souviens du petit cochon ?
L : Ouais.
[Fabien prend une voix "Cartoon"]
Dédé !!
Et deux à gauche,
ça fait deux G,
L : Comme GG comme les jeunes
marquent sur nos commentaires quand...
F : Ouais, mais ça, ce n'est pas
visualisable.
L : Ah, mince.
F : Un truc en GG, moi j'ai
la Gorgone.
F : Je pense souvent à la Gorgone
pour GG.
L : Je ne sais pas ce que c'est
le Gorgone.
F : Ah, tu sais c'est Méduse,
la femme avec les cheveux en serpents...
L : Aaaahhhh...
F : Ça te parle, ça ?
L : Ah ben maintenant ouais.
F: Ça ira, ça ?
L : Ouais, Gorgone. Ok.
F : Gorgone : Méduse.
F : Ah ! J'ai oublié d'appuyer sur "enregistrer".
F : Non, je rigole.
[Eclats de rires]
F : Je plaisante.
Ça m'est déjà arrivé, tu me diras...
L : Ah ouais ?
F : Je prends les 3 premières cartes.
Une... deux... trois.
F : C'est un Jocker, c'est noir.
L : C'est noir.
F : Est-ce que tu peux me dire
qu'elle image c'est, ça ?
L : Euh... Alors attends...
il y a deux de ce côté...
euh... un seul G c'était Gargamel,
et GG...
GG, je t'avais dis "ça fait le truc des jeunes"
t'as dit, oui ...
ben c'est Gor...
c'est la meuf avec des cheveux !
F : Voilà, c'est la Gorgone ;
les cheveux en serpents.
L : Ok.
F : Exactement.
L : Il n'y a que des zéros !
F : Il n'y a que des zéros.
L : Donc c'était Zorro.
F : Exactement !
F : Donc on a la Gogone et Zooro
euh...
est-ce que j'en...
Allez, je pousse un peu le vice.
On va en prendre un autre.
L : Et donc là t'avais...
Là, c'était 1...
F : Ouais.
L : Et donc c'était celui du milieu.
F : Oui.
L : Et celui du milieu,
c'était... Milou... ?
F : Exactement.
L : Ok. Gogone, Zorro, Milou.
F : On va créer une action avec eux.
C'est ça qui va être plus drôle.
Dans le premier spot de ta cuisine,
c'est à dire les tasses.
F : Quand tu rentres, sur la gauche, les tasses.
L : Ouais.
F : J'imagi... On va imaginer
qu'il y a la Gorgone, qui est là.
F : D'accord ?
L : Donc il y a la meuf avec tous ses cheveux
L : en serpents, qui est
F : ouais.
L : dans ma cuisine, au niveau
de mes tasses. Ok.
F : Au niveau de tes tasses, tu vois ?
F : Et elle est... euh...
F : peut-être qu'elle a plusie urs tasses,
qu'elle les tient comme ça,
L : Ouais...
F : Et qu'il y a les serpents
de ses cheveux qui sont
en train de boire dans les tasses,
carrément. Là tu vois ?
L : Très bien !
F : Elle leur donne à boire comme ça.
L : Ok.         Ok.
F : Ok ?
Et juste à sa droite,
toujours au niveau des tasses,
il y a Zorro qui est là, en fait.
L [Approuvant] : humm, humm
F : Il y a Zorro qui est là, à côté,
qui la regarde...
L : En mode "Mais qu'est-ce que tu fais,
t'as un problème dans ta vie".
F : En mode "Qu'est-ce que tu fais,
t'as un problème dans ta vie"...
L : Ok.
F : Alors que c'est lui qui a un problème,
parce qu'il est en train de
tenir Milou en laisse.
L : Ok !
F : Ok ?
[Musique]
L : On est toujours chez moi,
et il se passe toujours des trucs
de fous dans ma cuisine.
Dans mon évier :
Il y a Milou, qui est tranquilou,
dans son petit bain, qui fait sa life.
Mais, ce dont il ne s'est pas rendu compte,
c'est qu'il s'est mis à l'intérieur de mon évier
où j'avais fait tremper les serpents
pour le repas.
Tu vois, les serpents de la tête de Méduse,
que j'avais coupés un à un,
un après l'autre.
Et là il y a Hulk qui arrive dans la cuisine
et qui commence à gueuler :
"Mais c'est quoi ce bordel ?
Dans l'évier, il y avait les serpents !
na na na, na na na..."
[Musique]
F : Le but, après, quand tu recherches ça,
c'est d'aller dans ton palais mental.
Donc tu as compris qu'un palais mental
c'était une zone que tu connaissais,
avec des endroits qu'on a définis.
L : Oui.
L : D'accord.
F : Tu en as 6 dans ta cuisine.
F : Tu vas aller dans ton palais mental,
tu vas avoir les images, les scènes qui vont te revenir.
Il faut que tu décodes ces scènes
en cartes... ensuite.
L : Gorgone, c'est quand il y avait les GG
GG. Donc c'est noire, noire, rouge.
F : Exactement.
Noire, noire, rouge.
F : On continue.
L : Ensuite, on a Zorro.
Et Zorro, c'est quand il y a des zéros.
Du coup, c'était :
rouge, rouge, rouge.
F : Rouge, rouge, rouge.
L : Ah, ah !!
L : Et ensuite on avait Milou,
qui est le mec du milieu,
donc c'était rouge, noire, rouge.
F : Rouge, noire, rouge.
L [Chantant] : Yeah, baby come on...
F : C'est pas Ouf déjà ?
L : J'suis trop forte ! J'suis trop forte.
F : Vas-y, on continue. Deuxième spot.
L  : Attends !
L : La deuxième histoire, c'était l'histoire
qui se passait... euh... dans...
euh... là où il y a ma machine à laver, machin...
Excalibur ça encercle.
Donc ça veut dire, si je me souviens bien,
que c'était noire, rouge, noire...
F : Noire, rouge, noire.
L : Ensuite on a Donald qui sort le linge.
Et Donald, c'était le D, donc c'était vers là-bas
et c'était rouge, rouge, euh...
rouge, rouge, noire.
F : Rouge, rouge, noire.
L : Et ensuite, euh... on a donc Donald
qui sort le linge et il voit la méduse
et la méduse c'était bien, euh...
moi je pense à GG en fait,
donc c'était bien :
noire, noire, rouge.
F : Noire, noire, rouge.
L : Yeeeeeaaaaaahhhhhh !!!!
L : Dans mon évier, il y a Milou...
F : Tu peux me le traduire de suite Milou ?
L : Oui.
F : Comme ça, c'est pour vous faire voir
aussi la démarche de traduire
tout de suite dans sa tête.
L : Ok. Donc dans mon évier il y a, euh...
rouge, noire, rouge.
F : Rouge, noire, rouge.
L : qui est en train de faire le bain.
mais en fait on se rend compte
qu'à l'intérieur de l'eau
il y a aussi le... euh...
noire, noire, rouge.
F : Noire, noire, rouge.
L : Et là, à un moment, il y a Hulk
qui arrive et qui pète un câble,
et lui c'est le... Hulk, c'est le super fort ;
C'est pas le noire, noire, noire, lui ?
F : Ben si, c'est l'ultime.
L : Ah, ben voilà.
F : Noire, noire, noire.
F : Ok.
L : Et alors, le dernier...
F : Tu continues ?
L : Ouais, c'est l'histoire des chiens.
qui n'est pas une histoire facile à raconter
parce que j'ai toujours des traumatismes.
[Rires]
F : Tu traduis au fur et à mesure.
L : D'accord. Donc...
Mais elle était facile.
L : Je m'en souviens très bien.
F : Ben du coup, ouais...
L : C'était, euh... noire... attends !
C'était : rouge, noire, rouge.
Rouge, noire, rouge.
Yeeeaaaahhhh !
[Rires]
F : Euuuuhhhh.....
L : Et ben ouais ! Et ben voilà.
F : Trente-six... Tu as retenu 36 cartes.
L : Concrètement, dans la vie,
ça peut me servir à quoi, en fait,
d'avoir appris cette technique là ?
F : Alors, là, c'est une application directe
pour faire les cartes ;
Donc ça ne sert à rien,
à part à s'entraîner,
à se faire des images,
ou... euh... ou à se la raconter
pour se faire un défi avec quelqu'un.
Tu vois ?
L : Humm, humm.
F : Mais le but de ça,
c'est surtout de s'habituer
à faire du palais mental.
L : Aaaahhh, oui d'accord.
F : A faire de l'image,
à poser des images, etc...
Pour utiliser d'autres systèmes,
qui sont, eux, plus sophistiqués
et qui vont vous permettre de retenir
encore plus de choses après.
L : D'accord.
F : Au moins ça donne un sens à l'entraînement.
L : Mais c'est génial.
F : Tu vois.
L : Ok.
F : Merci !
L : Ben, de rien.
F : Le Corps, la Maison, l'Esprit !
L : Ben de rien.
L : Et comme tu as pu voir,
dans ma cuisine il se passe des trucs de fou !
Du coup, si tu veux savoir ce qui s'est passé
d'autre ; les chiens qui sont contre les murs,
les trucs qu'il y a dans ma machine à laver...
Je t'invite à venir voir sur ma chaîne.
Ouais, je suis une meuf comme ça,
je me fais de la pub.
F : C'était trop bien dit.
L : Et ouais...
F : Mais j'ai rien à ajouter.
Le Corps, la Maison, l'Esprit,
je vous mets le lien dans la description
évidemment
Vous pouvez également cliquer ici
pour vous abonner à Laetitia,
ou aussi pour vous abonner à moi.
Et si vous avez aimé,
vous pouvez liker et...
L : partager !
F : Rendez-vous bientôt.
sûrement en début de semaine prochaine.
CIAO.
[Musique Générique de Fin]